one silver lining to fewer movies coming
out this year a chance to theorize about
some of the best classics of yesteryear
take for instance the hottest movie from
when i was in middle school
titanic it's got everything you'd hope
for in a summer blockbuster iconic lines
romance time travel wait time travel
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where i'll never let go i'll
never let go
of theories about movies that were
released before most of the people
watching this video were born
seems like every year i have a good
excuse to use this tweet
can't do this anymore and who boy was
2020 the peak year to exemplify that
feeling
so instead this holiday season i wanted
to take us all on a quick trip
back in time to the year 1997.
things were just simpler back then games
had just started breaking out into the
third dimension
it was literally impossible to be on the
phone and on the internet at the same
time and there were only three star wars
movies it was also a time where i owned
zero pairs of jeans it's not to say that
jeans weren't commonly available there
was just a period of time in my life
where i thought it was a good idea to
wear suit pants but anyway it is hard to
state
how big of a movie james cameron's
titanic was back in 1997. when this
thing was released titanic was the most
expensive movie ever made but it also
became the highest
grossing movie ever made being the first
film to ever break the one billion
dollars earned at the box office mark
and remember we're talking about 1997
money here
and it stayed on top of that leaderboard
until a different james cameron movie
about weird blue aliens came along to
beat it it has the record of being
nominated for the most oscars
winning the most oscars the theme song
my heart'll go on was the most played
song on the radio for 10
straight weeks which honestly in my
memory feels too low because you could
not step
into a circuit city in the late 90s and
not hear that song and even though
titanic runs at a hefty
three hours and 14 minutes which fun
fact was a very specific time because it
was the exact time it took the ship to
sync in real life it's also the digits
of pi
people still went to see it in the
theaters over and over and over again
even though there were no super villains
in it unless of course you count the
iceberg hashtag historical spoilers my
point is that titanic was a
dominating cultural force and i get that
this channel tends to work best when i
focus on animated stuff and superheroes
but
man this is a movie that we need to talk
about and it's not like i haven't been
asked to either i get a lot of requests
to cover whether leonardo dicaprio's
character of jack could have fit on the
floating rubble that saved his
girlfriend rose but i've shied away from
that theory because one
mythbusters already did a deep dive into
the topic i've watched enough episodes
of deadliest catch to know that when you
plunge yourself into cold water without
a survival suit you're gonna freeze to
death
pretty darn soon but also number two the
question is missing the point entirely
jack had to die jack wanted to die
because jack is a time traveler i know i
know that sounds
crazy but it's true jack on the titanic
is a time traveler who was there on the
boat to make sure that the titanic
sank and if you think that's a hot take
just you wait cause this episode is
gonna get steamier than the window of
jack and rose's make-out mobile so put
on your life jackets theorists cause
today we're plunging into the icy
iceberg infested waters of titanic's
time travel
now in order to follow this theory and
several of the references i just made to
titanic you need to have a good idea of
how the movie goes so here's a quick and
spoiler heavy recap for you
in the 1990s a team of scientists is
excavating the wreckage of titanic
a massive passenger ship which crashed
85 years before
during their search they find an old
brand unsafe drawing of a lady named
rose wearing a necklace that contains
a massive diamond named the heart of the
ocean and as luck would have it she's
still alive and can tell him the story
of the titanic's cursed voyage from
there most of the rest of the movie just
boils down to rose telling her tale
how she boarded the titanic with her
rich fiance cal who is just
the worst human being and how to get out
of her miserable relationship she
decided to jump
overboard to kill herself however as
she's about to do it she's spotted by
jack a poor third class passenger who's
only on the titanic because he won a
ticket in a poker game
jack is charming enough that it makes
rose not want to die and it doesn't take
long for her to realize
that she likes jack's nude illustrations
and below deck drinking parties a whole
heck of a lot more than her fiance's
misogyny then the boat hits a huge ice
cube and breaks in half there aren't
enough lifeboats for everybody so rose
ends up floating on a piece of debris
while jack
chills out in the water literally it
turns out submerging yourself in icy
water is bad for you so jack freezes to
death while rose is rescued when one of
the lifeboats turns around and picks her
up at the end of her life she dumps the
heart of the ocean back into the sea
because um
because uh it's a symbol or something of
her
love of jack and then she dies cause she
real old the end now titanic as a whole
is an entertaining love story and it has
the added bonus of leonardo dicaprio
chasing after a young woman
just like in his real life only this
time it's age appropriate but what isn't
as immediately apparent about this story
is that
jack isn't just a poor third class
passenger jack
is a time traveler specifically on the
boat to complete
a mission oh yeah now we're getting into
the crazy pills territory of this theory
but it's not crazy at all when you think
about the things that
jack says that no one from 1912 could
possibly know
let's look at a few examples as he's
freezing to death in the north atlantic
jack accurately predicts rose's fate
you're gonna die an old lady
warm in her bed all right all right that
one's a little bit tongue-in-cheek it's
a last-minute pep talk as you're on the
verge of death no problem but how about
one of the very first things that jack
mentions to rose when he discovers her
dangling over the railing of the ship i
remember when i was a kid
me and my father we went ice fishing out
on lake with soda seems plausible enough
right
nothing out of the ordinary there well
this conversation between jack and rose
is happening in
april of 1912 but lake wisoda is a
man-made lake which was created between
and 1917. even if jack is lying about
the memory there's no way that he could
know the name of a lake that didn't
exist yet
and this also isn't the only time it
happens he does it again when he's
telling rose about their imaginary trip
to the santa monica pier
ride on the roller coaster till we throw
up not necessarily the most
charming pitch for a date but that's
missing the point he's referring to the
blue streak racer roller coaster which
wasn't on the santa monica pier until
and it's not just things that jack says
either when he and fabrizio are rushing
to board the titanic we see fabrizio
carrying this bag
that bag is called a moose sack and
here's where i'll pause moment to let
you giggle about that and also give you
a moment to subscribe to the channel
help push us over the 10 million
subscriber mark we good
alright so that rucksack became popular
after its initial use as a pack for the
swedish military in world war
ii starting in 1939. even if jack had
been guessing about future roller
coasters and man-made lakes how on earth
does he have a physical item that wasn't
produced until
27 years after he died unless
he's hopping timelines how does jack
have this power
why would he go back in time and the
most important question of all
why did he choose that haircut if he was
trying to blend into the scenery in
1912.
now hold on you stalwart advocates of
occam's razor are probably saying isn't
there a simpler explanation here that
rose is just
making jack up after all as one of the
researchers mentions to rose at the end
of the movie
we never found anything on jack there's
no record of him at all
but as rose says there shouldn't be
records of him because jack never
purchased his own ticket which he didn't
he won them playing poker in a bar
five minutes before the ship left all
the more reason the dude is a time
traveler leaves no trace of his
existence
gets on the boat via a fluke chance of
luck right before it takes off and let's
be honest if rose were making jack up
who drew the sexy time picture of her
that they found in the safe he
definitely existed and he definitely is
a time traveler heck
if you need further proof look no
further than the movie's director james
cameron
writer and director of iconic science
fiction films like aliens the abyss
avatar elita battle angel mastermind
behind other time travel classics like
the terminator and terminator 2.
look at the dude's entire filmography
everything is sci-fi
and action you know the one movie that
just doesn't make sense
titanic until you consider that it's
low-key a sci-fi
time travel movie so whether you buy
into that or not just go with me on this
why why would a time traveler go back to
the titanic
just have a fling with this rich girl
only to die in the end and why wouldn't
he choose to
i don't know save the freaking boat if
he knew what was coming well you see one
thing that's undeniable is that jack
saving rose
changes the course of history if jack
doesn't see rose stepping over the rail
and she actually jumps the titanic
doesn't sink consider this once her
fiance cal or her mother notices that
she's missing
they'd report it to the crew at which
point standard procedure is to turn the
boat around and
attempt a search and rescue but the
titanic is a big ship that you can't
just throw in reverse so in order to go
back and search for rose they'd likely
need to make what's called a williamson
turn which is a teardrop
shaped maneuver that large ships use to
reverse course and requires a
significant
detour and then there's the actual
search what matters here isn't whether
the search and rescue is successful what
matters is the change of timing
changing the course of the ship alone is
time consuming the official inquiry into
the crash
found that it took over 30 seconds and
nearly half a kilometer for the ship to
turn
22 and a half degrees in an attempt to
avoid the iceberg so doing a full 180
degree loop is gonna take several
minutes
the ship then has to retrace its path
back once they discover rose is missing
and then there's the time of the actual
search and rescue
it's impossible to come up with an exact
figure of how much of a delay rose
jumping overboard would cause but if
we're considering the bare
minimum of 15 minutes to turn the ship
around and go back to the point of
rose's disappearance a
shockingly cursory 30-minute search and
then another 15 minutes to get back on
course
we're looking at at least an hour of
delay which again
realistically i think it would have been
much longer than that even one
hour though changes history because
icebergs travel in the water on average
about 0.7 kilometers every hour
and often faster than that depending on
the current so it's safe to say that the
iceberg which sank the titanic in real
life would have been
thousands of feet away if the titanic
had been delayed by an hour
or more with no iceberg to hit the ship
now enters new york harbor safely and
rose's death
ends up saving 1500 lives suck on that
butterfly
effect ashton kutcher so then jack was
real but also a time traveler who
saved rose to make sure that 1500
other innocent people would die why
would he travel back in time to ensure
the destruction of the boat rather
than prevent it well maybe it's not that
simple maybe jack dawson was sacrificing
the 1500 lives lost on the titanic to
save
a million lives and preserve the course
of history hear me out on this one let's
say the titanic hadn't sunk
rose jumps overboard the ship is delayed
it misses the iceberg and the titanic is
now the new fad in transatlantic travel
it travels back and forth between new
york and southampton carrying
thousands and thousands of passengers
until one day in 1914 or 1915
it's torpedoed and sunk by a german
submarine
killing the thousands of people on board
now while that might seem like it's
coming out of nowhere like it is
completely random
we actually have ourselves a historical
comparison in may of 1915 the british
passenger ship lusitania was sunk
by a german u-boat killing over a
thousand people
including 128 americans and the
lusitania was attacked
just off the southern coast of ireland
which is right on the route titanic was
taking between southampton
and new york so we know that the german
navy would have been
in the area with an opportunity to sink
the titanic now in 1915 the united
states was neutral in the recently
started world war one though they were
helping to supply the british using
ships like the lusitania to do so but
germany declared the waters around the
united kingdom and ireland a war zone
and while it's speculation to say that
they would have torpedoed the titanic
let's just say that their history of
being perfectly honorable in world wars
wasn't exactly stellar the sinking of
the lusitania raised anti-german
sentiment among americans but the us
still stayed out of the war until 1917
as part of a surge that ultimately won
the war for the allies but if it had
been the titanic rather than the
lusitania
there would probably have been many more
americans on board and if there were no
war material on board the unprovoked
nature of the attack would have been too
egregious for president woodrow wilson
to keep the us
out of the war after all history has
shown us that american sentiment can
turn to war when it perceives an
unprovoked attack against the country
like pearl harbor the sinking of the
main
or entering the war in iraq so the
titanic sinking via iceberg
kept us out of world war 1 maybe so what
big deal the us was instrumental in the
allied forces winning the war so
why would it matter well it's true the
u.s was mostly successful in world war
one but most historians agree that
joining world war one in its early
stages say 1914 or 1915
rather than when we actually entered in
1917 would have been disastrous for the
united states the standing army of the
us in 1915 was smaller
and less experienced than the forces
from the major players in world war one
but also smaller and less experienced
than the forces of bulgaria
and greece the main opponent of the
united states in the war
germany had an army 20 times the size of
the us's at that point to position the
united states as an international power
many american politicians led a campaign
known as the preparedness movement in
the early days of world war one to
increase the size of the military
train them more thoroughly and invest in
updates to equipment and machinery the
gradual onset of this program proved
useful for the us in the later days of
the war but if the u.s had entered the
war in its early stages it's likely the
preparedness movement would have enacted
their plan to draft 600
000 young men annually and send them to
the front lines immediately without
adequate time to prepare them
proper equipment to send them to battle
with and only rudimentary scouting of
the war front in western europe american
casualties likely would have skyrocketed
as world war 1 played out in history the
us lost approximately 116
000 men in the last stages of the war if
the u.s had joined earlier though with
mobilized but untrained troops fighting
in the trenches it's likely that that
number of casualties would have been
closer to austria-hungary's 1.1
million deaths france's 1.4 million or
germany's
whopping 2 million heck the war may have
even been
lost as american troops and supplies get
burned out early rather than giving the
allied forces a late game boost to carry
them over the victory line
so let's take that all back to titanic
though jack's decision to save rose
caused the titanic to sink and cost
1500 people their lives he may have done
it to save the united states from a
timeline that would have cost them
over 1 million lives and with that kind
of decimation
who knows how the u.s turns out for the
remainder of the 20th century
maybe americans never land on the moon
never become world leaders in
information technology or worst of all
never develop the world's premier film
market that can afford to fund a 200
million
movie to give leonardo dicaprio his big
break that's right friends leonardo
dicaprio's character is a time traveler
who made sure the titanic
sinks to prevent an alternate history
where the career of actor leonardo
dicaprio
never exists but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and
cuts
[Music]
you